plaza tahir el corazón del levantamiento
popular de egipto a partir del 25 de
enero de 2011 miles de manifestantes se
reunieron bajo la atenta mirada del
ejército pidiendo un cambio inmediato
durante lo que llamaron un día de rabia
bajo la creciente presión de las
protestas callejeras el presidente hosni
mubarak renunció y salió del cairo con
su familia el 11 de febrero espero que
algún día esta revolución de enero pueda
traernos lo que hemos pedido ban
libertad justicia social y dignidad se
celebraron elecciones legislativas y
para la sorpresa de todos los islamistas
obtuvieron dos tercios de los escaños de
los diputados en un punto de inflexión
histórico el candidato de los hermanos
musulmanes mohamed morsi se convirtió en
el primer presidente elegido
democráticamente
mors y prestó juramento el 30 de junio
de 2012 sólo unas semanas después del
juicio sin precedentes de mubarak pero
este breve experimento de democracia
terminó en julio de 2013 con el
derrocamiento y arresto de morse
a pesar de las protestas en las calles
un nuevo régimen autoritario respaldado
por el ejército tomó el control en mayo
de 2014 por el 97% de los votos el ex
ministro de defensa el general
abdelfatah al sisi fue elegido
presidente el parlamento adoptó
rápidamente una nueva constitución que
fortalecía los poderes del ejército una
al cis ya envalentonado lanzó una feroz
campaña para reprimir las voces
disidentes
las ong denunciaron violaciones a los
derechos humanos tras la detención de
miles de partidarios de morse una década
después de la revolución a pesar de una
mejora en la economía las ambiciones
democráticas de egipto aún no se han
cumplido